how's it going bros my name is Pierre
welcome to um normally I am playing
enough live it should be nine German -
selenium I highly know what I was
kidding that was bad I was bad hope I
don't have you what the heck what no
no why no that's impossible did I have
my period already no way no that imagine
possible
nice chirping extra penny you had your
shout out mr. chair just shut your mouth
all right
let's treat this I hate this cruel
letter if I have very little time to
write as my companion sits outside the
door feeling in the gross and hores
appeared overnight nobody knows what
they are or where they came from all we
know is that we had to get you to safety
you passed out shortly after one of
those things attacked you I brought you
to your sanctum to pray that you will
awake shortly and rid us the hell did
you do I don't know penny I am watching
me
don't Gaiman I'm not ready and I'm
cherish don't look it's creepy it's
creeping me out okay okay for now why
Sir freakin violent in here I hate
violence
alright let's fix it see what's going oh
the [ __ ]
it's like period everywhere Wow Oh
[Applause]
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but I
today I know it goes away visit yeah
alright time out activate pop up okay oh
bike okay it's going are you kidding me
alright come on
I didn't that wasn't me
[Music]
we good nope not good I don't he forgot
about me up then it all right come on
to the window my child do not fail them
the blackness of the fight block in mr.
sharp thank the show I don't even care
huh no I know he's such an [ __ ] okay
oh [ __ ] it I'd the pain of the fall
shook me to my variables as blackness
engulfed me I believed myself to be dead
the horror that I had seen was certainly
not of this world
I'm alive
I'm alive this America praise the chair
I did a pity I did I saved you
I'm loud you should praise me I painted
I picked you tell you it's nice it's
pretty nice don't you think so bad lazy
that though it's kind of creepy house I
don't know I have a artistic central
minor yes all right dear father I write
to you in hopes that being able to
decipher the meaning of the sketch I
left on your board
I recently on the psyching a patient
appears to be suffering from some sort
of demeans dementia he's been repeating
phrase in the foreign language the only
in speak the English and stuff like that
and he's slumber hopefully you can make
sense of a sketch Brad there moth fuzz
at work meeting the I regard likes me I
forgot the key in your supply just so I
liked the biosketch who's doing the
creepy background noise listen you mr.
closet
mr. potatoes no okay
what is that father Island I need your
assistance really my patient escaping
from my clinic this morning and neither
is Justin tracking him down his mental
condition is stable not stable he's
fried by the call lash of cause injury I
lost them heading down the valley in a
random twine my hair but there's like no
gonna keep your eye on your back where
we go dr. Smith all right that's pretty
cool now
wow this customer is pretty [ __ ] cool
I'm not gonna lie
all right I want to know who saved my
life
wait I think he looks for the doctor
come on
I totally miss bear all right yeah it's
me hello Doug what are you doing you're
a damn fine dog I tell you but why is
that a freaking saw inside you it makes
no sense okay then the box
hello dr. Smith back thirst man my sir
is that dog in your hallway okay okay
move away mr. chef I know I was just
reading around I'm sorry huh
at that hand why not okay
and I've seen plenty of that handsome
before I mean I didn't we like I mean of
course they're okay
oh that's a lot of Scully's didn't wanna
Scully's for me to count oh [ __ ] I don't
even see it a week it's more than six
days it comes before Friday after
suddenly it's Friday Friday gotta get
down on Friday everybody's looking for a
pretty pie on the week gals we damn
frying and frying I'm supposed to find
something in here I think way there's
it's just so hard to see
so sexy
family mr. sofa everyone has a mister on
it Atos pity I was hanging out with my
cousin he's a he's okay but he's not
cold in addition you know all right what
are we doing
tell me tell me status reports meeting I
don't know I'm just I'm just like if our
staff and our you are you never find
stuff do you
you're worthless I tell you worthless
just like your mother
what what did you say nothing nothing
nothing I'll just leave you here for
looking all right fine
okay but there it yeah it didn't break
up back it's impossible back right back
yeah yeah we gotta teach him not to mess
with me
[Music]
that was Susan we need to find a key or
something I mean we'll find a no wait
maybe my I lost my cabana Josie you know
below gives a spine pain nothing can
even faint
how's that oh well we got leave the
Gosselin ah darn it maybe they am
friggin serious this time you hit me so
many [ __ ] times I'm so freakin pissed
at oh we got some oil and and a 10-5 all
right this way pity I can smell it it's
this way God okay
[Music]
I have no idea what's going on but I
don't like this let's go to the forest
this way yes
Casa of course I'm stuck now we're stuck
what why did you do that three day huh I
did it I saved your life you should
thank me okay
I'm glad let's go I can't go oh my
you should have Thomas if I was kidding
with you of course I was just testing
you and you failed you failed my test
now go back inside look for my clothes
you stupid bat Falls Brad ten too much
sweet how could I miss my language oh
that's embarrassing
I told you pudding I frigging Talia you
failed the test again no power cake
can't go in there
maybe now we can go to the basement or
something
[Music]
probably not wait what's here what is
this what's going on here I don't we
totally find something naked girls in
alley welcome wider since triphase
approached me and police pressed by palm
against my my earth against it is he
telling was she telling married
was she telling me to touch her oh okay
I was just kidding I'm tired I'm sorry I
like it no I'm sorry I if I do you like
it oh can I at least have the chest
please okay I'd like to I think
come on I need that thing in the chest
whatever it is always like a bun oh it's
like a bunch of oil and if you're good
you get them and if you're I was good I
think good yeah I think you did the
height choice booty huh that's like good
for anyone I still can't go in here I
really don't know where you got okay
maybe now we can find something easier
I don't know I don't even know anymore
[Music]
Wow okay maybe in his butt did you shake
his best booty
I didn't but somewhat friggin Scully's
it's crazy okay
we need to figure out what you do I
almost took the wrongs but don't talk to
my cousin he's freaking crazy don't go
near him like he's alright but it's out
but the [ __ ] they didn't focus I told
you that [ __ ] not too pretty kill
yourself ok ok ok that's a bad dog
you're so damned kind that night I don't
understand what's going on
I'm gonna put you here by the piano
smile you can pulse told you to pulse
not to die I mean you're not that
sivanna okay everyday I'm getting
serious pissed off at this mud go look
at the lady again
[Music]
and you're out of oil great oh wow
really
can't return good for your bidding good
for you you stupid ass okay oh I have
the key you guys are gonna hate me I
know it you guys are gonna be like ah
you have the gayest oh wait it doesn't
even work there huh doesn't even work
there Keith for medicine chest what what
medicine chests there's no chest
except that lady we just touch your
badge where's the medicine chest
tell me mister shares don't hide secrets
from me
alright alright don't say it's obvious
it's not obvious I know it's not obvious
don't don't you dare say it don't keep
freaking dare where's the medicine chest
here no it's not a chest frickin box
nothing really
[Music]
all right
yeah that's good hump the wall
I come up here such every time how's
that 3/16 house that was in a place
exhale someone ate it you stupid ass huh
okay fine let's go here probably in some
chest hair that a mess I don't know
medicine chest oh yeah yeah okay let's
do this
perfect huh glad none of them oil send a
fighter fight without that's a lot of
stuff I feel a lot better now but I
still don't know where to go
like this still makes no sense
what are you doing up I don't know I
just wanted to break down sit down a
problem
[Music]
mr. pop you're gonna save my life
really Wow it's an honor Petey it's an
honor to say you're like go I did
nothing